things are better the world is better
just because there's not a war doesn't
mean there's peace
he's coming some call him apocalypse he
was some kind of God for thousands of
years he's been amassing mutants to take
their powers
he always had four followers like the
four horsemen Erik don't join them
whatever it is you think you saw on me I
buried it with my family to be a man we
will cleanse the earth everything
they've built will fall and from the
ashes of their world
we'll build a better one I've never felt
power like this before
they took him present the world needs
the x-men I'm not a hero
students we look up to you if I'm going
to teach your kid something I'm going to
teach them how to fight follow me
jaha I'm not afraid of him I need oh
he's my father
what remember my mom yeah I know
not all of us can control our powers
then don't
apocalypse means to destroy this world
it's all of us against a god and the
most powerful beings on earth
forget everything you think you know
none of that matters
you're not students anymore I'll take
everything from that your x-men
well you've been busy
you had a little help everything they
feel will fall and from the ashes of
their world
we'll build a better one
sinking like stones all the way
apocalypse means to destroy this world
let's go to war
everything
you